in northern Cambodia we're with doctors
on an urgent mission malaria is common
here but some of the drugs used to treat
it have started to fail now the team is
trying to find an alternative before
it's too late
we don't have effective anti-malarial
tracks most of people will die because
we don't have any traction treatment
we've been called to a suspected case of
malaria in a remote village a young
woman bitten by mosquitoes now suffering
from fever and pay a local health worker
is ready with a test kit when we arrive
a drop of 32 rod Wong's blood is taken
and then we wait so what does that mean
one line no malaria Huang's test is
negative thousands of others aren't as
fortunate malaria has been on the rise
here in 2016 there were 20,000 reported
cases from 2017 that had risen up to
50,000 and the problem is that drugs
resistance is also going up and that's
not just dangerous for people living
here but potentially for people around
the world of this spreads putting
millions of lives at risk isn't it
the clinic twelve-year-old duong is on
an Oxford University back trial
combining three anti-malarials
resistance to two of the most effective
drugs has spread from Cambodia to parts
of Thailand Lao and Vietnam
doctors hope adding a third medicine
will stop it in its tracks before it
reaches Africa previously when we had
the resistance to chloroquine back in
Africa we saw a massive upsurge in
deaths and morbidity from malaria it was
only because of their AC tees that came
along that we were able to kind of bring
that down and start getting more under
control but if we get failures from that
then we'll kind of go back to the dark
days I've seen all these deaths among
children and get into the case where we
might get malaria isn't treatable 22
year old bond Lai has finally recovered
from the disease
thanks to the new treatment he says in
the past the antimalarials he was given
didn't work i had the young clone anger
leukemia pay through her own blood
God Queen gender Kimbrough coat romanian
years yeah so don't not home not home
near him don't lie is right to be
worried more than 200 million people get
malaria each year so an untreatable
strain would be catastrophic
but if these scientists can beat the
parasites in Southeast Asia lives around
the world could be saved
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Cambodia